here we go again yeah but he's not
moving maybe remembering the last game
which was kind of a disaster okay for it
no Kings Indian that time but I also won
the last three way with black last
couple of games I was quite successful
against him I'm on minus two that's a
good good score in my book last time you
went d3m yeah again he's going for this
rather non theoretical way of playing
93 was the last game and t4 which I
think it's not that great actually yeah
maybe deform takes takes takes b3 that
that that might be more more like it how
do I play here I can go and I can still
go oh he's playing for this Knight g4
idea probably so let's push the five
whenever they tend to decentralize stuff
there I want to push in the center and
at least my way our firm on my
understanding let's say of the pollution
my cheeks I guess night f4 might be
useful yeah well he's not really
threatening that only five let's go back
here I can take take Bishop d7 for the
hanging look the only one so it cannot
take at the moment and maybe night air
force a move that is annoying for him
okay i knowi five is hanging
hmm
I don't know what I want to go f6 here
sure maybe it's not so bad c4 is not a
problem anyway off because of 94 night f
5 27 now I don't see a tactic maybe
don't see a tactic their queen d7 looks
like the normal normal news but it goes
into this kind of walking distance to
the king that's always a bit a bit
unsettling let's say
so Bishop f7 night f5 Bishop 36 maybe
nabbit doesn't really doesn't really do
anything
night before might be might be a move
for him huh I am not totally sure how to
play this but okay I'm 994 text c5 there
was a bad move it was just a band yeah
yeah of course yeah of course ah how ok
at least I can go back covering f6 and
covering c5 again see 494 s not on right
it's a blue that was you put my came
well at least f5 is now a threat maybe
he just has to go back I know he
probably won't yeah that was probably
not that bad am I mean 97 it was great
but didn't seem to UM be suicidal or
anything
mhm it probably does not want to remove
one of the nights because it looks kind
of passive but f5 is there and can I
don't think that's a particular reason
for why to believe that he's better
unless there really is some kind of
tactic so okay let's just step to the
side there f5 night g fiber says idea or
any kind of sacrifice there ok Queen f7
maybe just to have a look down covering
it a little bit still not really not
that I 1 h 7 h-7 yeah fall into one move
trickier out of this good position great
great great great age 70 just the stupid
one move I am that's the way to lose the
game black resigns yeah that was stupid
it was really really stupid and if
anyone is better here that's black yeah
I have a have a big Center and well he's
got to it nights that are up there for
tricks but that's really it so losing in
two moves is really really a shame um
the computer actually just wants to play
a five and says I'm much better
yeah I'm defending the mid down and I
mean well if that's not a center I don't
know what it is 93 is the comp
continuation and then this gym it's
still quite quite difficult and it's not
like very simple minus 0.7 by the comp
it's not that clear before I know I just
have to look at this and think about
what is d for doing yeah it is of course
looking at age 7 and I don't know what I
should do women Bishop f5 or so Queen f7
is of course not not the best move I
should play this f5 or maybe this if I
want to play a a prep move for a safe
move but now I completely I completely
blundered into that and that really
loses so now in five or Bishop g8
actually like this more because it's
been more controlled and it asks right
okay what are you doing there yeah
giving up your Center having your
bishops there that don't do anything and
so on there wyd really has some issues
in this position unless he's getting in
some kind of miracle sacrifice like a
Swedish is better so does this makes
lots of sense just to be safe and then
go from there thinking about night f4 or
night over there of what whatever
improvement maneuver I might come up
with but yeah blundering into h7 it's
not a good idea thanks for watching